l'épisode d'aujourd'hui est commandité
par martin matte et inand c'est une
compagnie québécoise effet des infusions
à base de yerba maté qu'une plante
sud-américaine qui procure les mêmes
effet énergisant que le café les
bienfaits du thé en plus d'une clarté
d'esprit qui vient sans palpitations
sans chute d'énergie c'est des boissons
qui sont 100 % bio c'est nicolas dans le
fond le fondateur qui est allé en trip 2
ce qui est né au chili qui a découvert
cette plante l'heure j'ai décidé de la
ramener ici qui retournait en fait
plusieurs fautes chili pour voir
vraiment la façon traditionnelle de
boire du thé petite plante là en fait
puis en revenant ici décidé de partir sa
compagnie pour pouvoir offrir cette
cette boisson là en fait aux québécois
ici ce que j'ai devant moi c'est la
version prêts à boire qui vient kahn est
donc déjà refusé c'est non pétillants ça
goûte un petit peu comme le thé glacé
donc vous pouvez la consommer comme ça
mais vous pouvez aussi si vous allez sur
leur site vous allez voir c'est super
bien expliquées consommer la feuille de
yerba maté en infusion traditionnelle
donc dans un espèce de petite tasse avec
une pas et filtrer donc vous buvez sabin
tranquillement ses ultras relaxe en fait
moi c'est ce qui le définit le
descriptif que je donnerais à ce donc
aller sur leur site web triple w pour un
math et inapte procès à m
ati n a point c'est à vous allez pouvoir
voir toutes leurs produits puis vous
allez pouvoir utiliser le code promo
sans filtre 15 en majuscules en un mot
pour avoir quelques pour cent de rabais
sur votre commande
donc merci à ma tei n'a de commencer
sans filtre puis je vous recommande
grandement leurs produits
une production du studio sf m'est venue
au sans filtre le podcast où on parle de
ce qu'on veut que nous inviter date si
tu fais h quand un avec moins d'hommes
plante un petit mot pour vous rappeler
qu'après chaque pas de casque on
enregistre au sans filtre enfin après
show qui est disponible exclusivement
sur notre pétrole
donc si vous avez aimé la conversation
que vous voulez nous entendre d'un mois
nicole parler plus longuement sur sur le
podcast convient tournée donner nos
impressions à chaud
dirigez-vous vers la page paix durable
qui est dans la description de ce
podcast ci sinon d'hommes cette semaine
cette semaine on a reçu maxence parrot
aussi connu sous le nom de max barrau
qui est un des meilleurs snowboardeurs
au monde québécois
tiken histoire vraiment extraordinaire
en fait qui devenues complètement
obsédées par le snowboard qui est
rapidement devenu un des meilleurs au
monde et que récemment en fait il ya
passé à travers une expérience une
épreuve très difficile qui était le
cancer mais il s'en est remis et
quelques mots après sa reddition il
gagné une médaille d'or aux x games
absolument incroyable c'est un gars
super inspirant que c'est toujours
vraiment inspire encore une fois de
rencontrer quelqu'un qui le meilleur ou
un des meilleur dans son domaine
c'est vraiment un gros prix village de
poids s'entretenir avec lui
ouais puis c'est rare qu'on attend qu'on
entend par dont max en français au
québec
techno bord je pense que c'est encore un
petit peu méconnu ici mais à
l'international
une soupe ulster puis on est vraiment
vraiment heureux qui nous est donné son
temps pour cette conversation là sinon
dans le fond participer aux
conversations privées dans les
commentaires ce que vous avez pensé de
notre entretien avec max puis partagé le
podcast par les ambrose a mis le cd tome
sera pas bon niveau à nos chaînes vous
connaissez le
patati patata une expression qui
existent pour connaissez peut-être pas
tort hyundai fait que bon podcast bonne
écoute
[Musique]
yes max merci d'être là ça vous tt cas
quand on fait des listes communes au
monde qui voulait qu'on m'invite sortait
tout le temps vraiment beaucoup
moi j'avais essayé de décrire par
instagram seront conquis mais j'imagine
que patrick et ibm où s'étaient postés
quoi fait que passer par par ton équipe
puis on est contents même que tu sois là
aussi et est offerte est venu si tu fais
tu là les retours que pour ce roi
cerrato bromont merci on entend rarement
parler en français ici au québec puis
j'ai l'impression que un poste comme
c'était le cas avec georges st pierre ou
et bac j'ai l'impression que cette
épreuve dans un sport qui est vraiment
plus gros à l'étranger ce que je me
trompe ben gros à l'étranger pas
nécessairement
je pense moi la passion que je vois si
c'est qu'il était quand même beaucoup de
montagne de neige au québec
le snowboard c'est connu au québec aussi
je pense c'est vraiment juste par
rapport aux nombres de par rapport à la
population qui est ici versus et aux
états unis ou en europe ou en asie en
résidence à métro 15 au sommet les
socios je peux voir les statistiques
publiées comme hors fêtes bien au canada
jusqu'à 20% d'ici fecteau au québec ça
doit peut-être 10% mais peut-être un peu
moins que fx pour ce qui était de mon
côté je me suis toujours en anglais sur
mes réseaux ainsi que mon public y est
majoritairement anglophone je sais que
des fois ça bouffe ça forge un peu les
québécois locomotives ainsi été filmé en
anglais mais je réponds que moi et m 6
80% de mes fans viennent d'ailleurs
petit point mais chouette on va perdre
des autres mais non c'est ce pays si on
n'a pas vraiment beaucoup de compétition
non plus au canada québec afin que c'est
beaucoup ailleurs dans le monde puis
tout ça fait dix ans que je voyage je
t'aime à travers les pays où est ce que
la maj fait que j'ai ramassé quand même
justement défendre à gauche à droite
puis je te dirais qu'au début quand j'ai
commencé à voyager j'avais 16 ans puis à
l'âge de 18 ans j'ai fait mes premiers x
games week end pour nous autres c'est
comme les jeux olympiques
comme les cheminots du monde
d'athlétisme
c'est exactement puis j'ai fini deuxième
puis il y en avait même pas parlé mais
j'ai un peu surpris parce qu'il tient
mettons à des fois on voit un autre par
un québécois qui vont dans un autre pays
puis on se bat maintenant un peu plus
connus mais s'il va finir dans la foulée
fini 7e 2 x games puis il paraît même
pas de -6 fait que ça va être chaud au
coeur au début mais parra ci de là
dessus ils ont vu que notre sport et
s'est rendu jusqu'aux années pic pour la
première fois quand j'avais 19 ans et
est la seule chaîne 2014 - 2014 sotchi
en russie
le scope star venait de rentrer et puis
le j'ai été là-bas
et puis le la faune j'ai commencé à
avoir des liens justement que les
journalistes avec la tv y ont commencé à
monsieur mes réseaux puis le salut
commencer de plus en plus en parler puis
aujourd'hui et puis comme un problème
chez chaque compétition romain schmit
derniers vont en parler
check est ton parcours le cpie tout ya
jamais eu de plan b est jamais autre
chose que c'est j'écoute une coupe de
temps très vite avec une entrevue est
papa de cartes parce que j'avais
baignade supprime c'était comme
à trois ans ce qui a 9 ans nos bords
depuis c'est comme si rien d'autre
ces piges en relief haiti façon
indirecte et parents peau les autres ont
fait et qui n'en foutent on veut finir
sur un bond à 5 mais gentil le fait de
kasma au secours de pouvoir faire du wpt
est vraiment en fait
quand tu te dis jamais eu de plan b en
fait j'ai dit que j'avais un plan b mais
dans le 4 et puis le stoppeur ça n'est
vraiment de plus en plus important pour
moi dans ma vie j'ai commencé ce combat
quand j'avais 9 ans au début j'étais
vraiment téléphone puis aujourd'hui
c'était vraiment pas peur plaisait puis
que je te sa montagne cinq jours
seulement après les soirs des caures se
joue le géant temps des quêtes des fois
qu'ils disaient tu dis que des fois tu
allais tu t'es acheté capable de faire
trois quatre pistes damas m couché de
cch minimes et d'avoir mes chiens peut
exactement puis j'ai changé parce que je
venais avec du monde un peu plus vieux
dans mes amis avec des autos puis quand
j'avais quand même temps 12 ans il y
avait les autos puis effet qu'il venait
me chercher chez nous puis me jeter à la
montagne on allait faire comme 4 5 4 5
descentes le soir avant de retourner à
l'école le lendemain puis des conditions
je me sens extrêmement chanceux d'être
né justement à bochum à côté de moi
c'est vraiment c'est grâce à ceux qui
l'ont rendue aujourd'hui mais dont qui
est au début c'est vraiment par pur
plaisir tout seul puis c'est à l'âge de
15 ans qui enfonce ne s'inscrit sur
facebook facebook n'est pas mal de clubs
puis j'ai commencé à suivre les progrès
de ce que je connaissais des films
d'affronter la vente vraiment juste des
films c'est la culture des films quand
même mais c'est la seule façon de voir
des proches ne l'est pas youtube n'avait
pas youtube y avait pas facebook
instagram donc j'écoute et des films à
chaque jour à chaque fin de semaine
depuis fait je connaissais les noms des
gars j'ai commencé à suivre sur facebook
puis belle tu commences à suivre chaque
jour voit qu'ils sont en suisse
aujourd'hui sont en autriche prochaine
son italie c'est juste que tu exprimes
mais là je commence à suivre leicester
puis jetée warhawk et le snowboard
pourrait m'amener à l'instar de même ça
serait vraiment cool max comme devenu un
peu mon rêve tranquillement puis c'est à
l'âge de 16 ans j'ai déjà un parrain
après son larcin
moi j'arrête je m'en foutiste nombreux
leur chaise bleue mais à ce moment même
dans ma famille du coup des mauvais
départ où je suis encore le seul
aujourd'hui de qom plusieurs générations
qui est pointé les universités qui
considèrent encore c'est une échec on
échapper pour moi pour mes parents c'est
vraiment important télé que bien une
poussette ou là dedans ça qu'est ce
qu'ils ont vraiment tombés de leur
chaise quand je dis moi je voulais l'or
chez les colts quel bol qui est fixée
s'est fait dans le fond j'ai comme quand
j'ai quelque chose j'ai quand même
appris dès mon jeune âge qu'il faut
toujours travailler toujours trouver une
façon de demain qui tapinent comme quand
j'avais 9 ans mes parents m'aient pochât
snobber fait que je me suis arrangée
pour avancer mais souvent même en
tournant un peu mais là tu en attendant
la pelouse puis un grand de l'argent je
me lâche 2,4 pièce le deux pièces et à
ce qu'a dit c'est vraiment des gros dire
si cela a pris comme justement justement
comme travailler quand j'étais jeune
puis à mes parents comme à chaque jour
j'aurai la force de le répéter encore
cette copie le après comme quelques mois
ils y ont dit à qui bon on va te laisser
un an après secondaire puis si ces
affaires vont bien de contenu si c'est
pas ben ben pourtant à l'école puis il
est pourtant l'école on veut toutes les
portes sont ouvertes
tu fasses chimie physique made for web
est restée tout en se rendant ce qui est
quand même très bon deal depuis jeudi je
suis mes parents ils veulent ema pour
moi puis jetée comme ça fait vraiment de
sens qui disaient mes portes pour que
soit ouverte par après je ne sais pas je
ferai ce nom c'est également qui est
parfait le plan b enfonce était de
retourner à l'école s'il saint jamais eu
lieu
non est ce que il ya quand je commençais
à faire du snowboard quand est-ce que tu
rapidement thorel direct avait un talent
un plus que la moyenne des gentils genre
de coordination de fear2 sensation de
ton corps dans l'espace plus que la
moyenne des gens ce que ce qu'il montre
que le disait ce quelque chose que tu
étais au courant c'est quand est de
quatre a commencé jeu en novembre et
c'est ce qui est tous des sports que
debuchy petit tout les sports je trouve
quand même appris ce quand même assez
vite mais je sais jamais vraiment le
meilleur non plus mais surtout parce que
je me tenais toujours du monde un peu
plus vieux que moi c'est qu'il y avait
plus d'expérience et de jouer un peu
meilleur je pense c'est ce qui m'a dit
justement a comme t'améliorer tout le
tard exactement ma mére plus rapidement
mais je faisais pas partie des meilleurs
le sable je penses tu que tu de
justement faisant mes recherches
c'est que tu avais de loi complètement
obsédé ne tire jamais eu rien d'autre
c'est justement ce téléfilm de ski cadet
de snow quand t'es pas en train d'enfer
piquante et pas en train de penser à ce
qu'elle sait pas ce qui s'est passé en
trampoline
est ce que parce qu'ils mettront versus
d'autres personnes à talent égal était
peut-être encore plus obsédé par vouloir
russie puis en france
je peux dire de loin je dois de la
personne aidée au monde quelque chose
mais mais mettons-les légaux ton calibre
et mettons humblement qui ont pas la
même éthique de travail que tous même
temps
non shit jugé
alors écoutez je me rappelle encore
quand j'étais au secondaire je pensais
juste snowball du matin jusqu'au soir le
tout et j'irai travailler ou gulf dans
le temps puis il y avait un bon autres
toiles fallait que je marche à chaque
fois qu'il allait porter un corps dans
le fond puis j'arrête tout droit chaque
fois puis je marchais sur bord des rues
n'importe où ce trouve toujours une
façon de transformer dans ma tête des
objets je vais trouver des façons tu es
la trampoline et et je me construis
d'aidés directes pour l'été avec un
skateboard avec des choses dessus que
showtime pratique est passé ça aussi qui
tue qui c'est au québec qu'on a dans
l'ange trois mois par année fait que
telle et les autres nombreux amont ils
peuvent en faire toute l'année puis moi
je peux savoir 3 qui a trois quatre mois
fait il fallait vraiment que je suis
créatif et récréatif tous les façons de
m'améliorer plus vifs accès quoi les
méthodes qui te trouver pour j'imagine
des photos les corps humain pour
l'enfant ben c'est ça j'ai commencé à
voyager à l'âge de 16 ans un petit peu
au début juste les compétitions puis
alors j'ai 17 ans le jeu vraiment le jeu
voyager partout au monde pour
m'entraîner vraiment l'année longue
la nouvelle métayer l'australie ou
exclure sur les glaciers fondent à
partir les 10 septembre oui j'ai
commencé puis ça jamais arrêté du 6 2
jusqu'à aujourd'hui les piscines où il
ya un espèce de gros ballons le centre
adam bague c'est vraiment génial parce
que c'est justement comme je disais
avant fallait tours géantes bizarrement
l'australie l'été je pensais comme trou
au moins là-bas
moi j'étais un gosse de famille un peu
j'aime mes amis j'ai ma famille j'aime
passer du temps d'où est-ce que ce que
je viens
puis parti trois mois en voyage je
trouve ça tough je veux dire d'un début
parce que je mentais j'avais beaucoup
d'argent non plus fait qu'il ferait ce
labeur et ce pour optimiser sur le plus
possible parce que faire beaucoup de
voyagement ça coûte cher mais
aujourd'hui j'ai plus commencer je
conseille de plus en plus d'entreprise
octobre puis dans le fond je pense ça
fait à peu près de quatre ans le dessus
mon coach de snowboard ou india un bag
et au japon là que ça l'a vraiment
danser avec moi ils reçoivent au japon
deux semaines à temps puis on a fait du
bag labonal fonds ont fait que c'est
vraiment un plastique compagnie
filaments de plastique que tu utilises
de sectes ont fait au moins tous les
sprints lui qui met de l'eau dessus pour
pour dans le fond ça serait que ça
glisse bien que ça colle pas puis c'est
vraiment un job de snowboard avec un bac
pour vos plats mais bien comme un cas
vraiment comme atterré les six tirs en
avant tout prix même rideout fait que
c'est pas comme tu atterris de tomblaine
de vraiment l'un des puits continue et
puis après ce titre me suis dit c'est
pas comme les jump le des fois il y
avait ça au relais à québec
vous voyez ça en corse c'est plus pour
les skieurs sa voix bien mais en
snowboard notre plateforme bat-il la
planche et aimant l'argent ça compte
vraiment qu'ils voient ce site dangereux
pour les genoux même s'ils mettent des
bulles dans l'eau ça fait pas au grand
écran différence fait que l'airbag sais
vraiment pas ce qui est vraiment l'un
des puits tout niveau de la sensation
c'est pas tellement différent que canal
va bien c'est quand même différent c'est
certain et il peut parcourir ebooks
article sinon tu glisses fait que c'est
vraiment que plus grand à droite tu fais
ton truc tu atterris mais la chose qui
est bien c'est qu'en fait c'est plus dur
que sur la neige
parce que justement il arrive au bout au
bout de soupe des center de trop de
poids sur un ace il faut que ce soit
vraiment patient sur le bout de sochaux
c'est plus dur sur l'âge ce qui est une
bonne chose de concentré là dessus avant
60 ans l'âge pierrick mans c'est plus
facile
mais dans le fond j'étais là comme 4 5 1
puis là on a trouvé là dessus puis
l'inde après mon coach en acheter un
puis en ce moment c'est encore le seul
qui est au canada
ici à sainte agathe des monts ce qui est
vraiment génial passé comme à deux
heures de route de chez moi donc je
m'entraîne maintenant traité puisse
aller vite justement que que j'ai passé
trois mois à l'autre bout du monde je
peux rester ici ma famille c'est août
chez htc ça doit être des bombes tout en
gérant ses 15 mai environ 250 cc qu'un
qu'est ce que tu aimes tu t'es dit ok là
je suis rendu un proche no border c'est
que que toi tu as vu que t'as vu la
première fois maintenant un chèque
rentrée de dire à qui n'ont su c'est ça
va me permettre de vivre là dessus
pendant pendant la prochaine année
thiais où est ce que le tout devient
professionnel quelque chose qui était
une qui était amateur a guest pour toi
ou est ce que tu vas qui n'ont le chu
rendu un professionnel de ce sport il ya
eu un moment où est-ce que tu réalises
et sept pris conscience de ce web et
dans le fond mais quand j'ai commencé et
il faut voyager le monde puis c'est pas
ma job google permettant ce qui est dans
le fond je te sens tu passais mes
parents dans le fond dont les trois
enfants puis à chaque enfant
il me disait que kalin pays de
l'université puis moi j'étais un parent
ou le mépris universités je me suis
occupé des voyages il est juste
transféré l'argent dans dans mon jeu
si la dent donc ils ont fait donc j'ai
un enfant j'ai eu accès de l'argent pour
commencer à voyager c'est ce que thomas
puis c'est un prix deux ans à voyager
puis tigre une petite compétition était
déjà en nouvelle zélande
les accoutrements 5000 à bas tarifs
premières places petit gang
il faut dire qu'ils ont fait escale us
qui était pas trop le co-détenu fait
d'eux les deux voisins et si je me
débrouillais bensalah les guillemets
c'est vraiment alors j'ai 18 ans quand
j'ai été aimée prince games-services 12e
quant aux x games fait un podium après
ses commentaires ça vraiment été comme
je dirais comme le début de ma carrière
professionnelle au début de ce tirage
doyen de l'argent mais at il pas assez
pour en vivre non plus et j'ai réussi à
rembourser mes parents parce que je
voulais faire ça me permet de voyager
tout ce métier je reste encore chez mes
parents et je payais pour dépenses à la
maison non plus puis c'est peut-être
comme un autre 2 octobre avec les
excuses crois que dans la popularité du
sport eu l'effet shaun white qui s'est
fait de marquer à l'international que
moi mettons que je faisais ma le bas et
maintenant je prends mon exemple de moi
qui me connaissent et paul la scène du
snowboard
les médias se sont rapidement emparés
sean whyte comme étant l imagine le dieu
sur moi et je puisse aller vraiment
contribué à faire que le snowboard
étaient rendus main stream et non juste
un support d'extrême plus underground
c'est ce que voulait sentir de
l'intérieur ou pas du tout abbas est
arrivé un peu même avant que moi je
commence à voyager
tai shan y avait 12 ans très longtemps
et je pense que nous apprendre d'eux
maintenant aux 33 qu'ils avaient comme
20 ans qui est des rythmes
professionnelle puis dans le temps comme
je l'avais fait que la seule façon que
les athlètes pouvaient comme sponsor
c'est à travers les magazines à travers
les interviews la télé puis sinon ça
ferait les films puis chance à l'été a
fait c'était comme le seul à faire les
ingrédients puis à faire vraiment des
abus dans les magazines autre que le
sport fait pour ça qu'il est devenu un
peu comme la vedette du snowboard puis à
menacer les réseaux sont partis puis on
ne connaissait branché
mais c'est certain que les réseaux
aujourd'hui nous a aidé beaucoup en fait
tous les autres athlètes salade un peu
plus tout le monde justement à monter
mais oui c'est ce qui est un droit qui
l'ya aidé beaucoup notre sport à se
faire connaître mondialement le statu
quo tête et qui de ce fait comme un une
deux ou un autre prince charmant parce
qu'il ya un fauchage oui beaucoup
beaucoup entendu sur l'afpa inquiet puis
modja pas que j'en fais pas ça du tout
je fais tout jamais j'en fais un petit
peu pour le fun mais c'est vraiment pour
moi c'est vraiment ce qu au stade
béguère ce que chez moi qui ai fait
aussi dans le passé mais quand j'ai
commencé à en faire ayant faisait déjà
plus vraiment qu'est ce qui te qu'est ce
qui fait que tu choisis une discipline
comme celtic est ce qui fait que tu dis
ah ben moi vigueur c'est ce jeu me forte
ben je pense que tu choisis
nécessairement c'est comme ça ça la rive
de même puis pour moi ce que je viens de
bromont puis à bromont on ne peut pas
être en fait au québec le seul aspect
qui avait même quand j'étais jeune
c'était à stoneham fait ici comme de 2,3
pour aller faire voyager après l'école
non c'est exact donc à bromont on avait
des duels
puis des jobs ce qui fait le slopestyle
enfants puis etienne a en fait sur la
scène de snowboard tout le monde fait du
sauvetage fait du bio qu'est-ce qu'on ne
peut pas juste les besoins et de ses
leaders
en fait même aux olympiques quand elle
choisit pas ton pays tu es obligé de
faire les deux quais puis le sk bromont
plus toi ta carrière de venez avec ce
but avec deux succès en ta carrière est
ce qui a amené tu pouvais aller voir la
montagne pareil ça peut-être que je
prendrais tu es ce set up le
ici où t'as jamais fait ce nom j'ai
jamais je ne pense pas que j'aurais pu
faire
c'était probablement mais il y avait
rien qui qui me dérange c'est mon goût
j'avais toujours de quoi apprendre à
chaque jour mais ce qu'il fait
aujourd'hui justement quand je vois dans
une montagne quelconque ce soit bromont
ou ailleurs [ __ ] mais ton il ya un
setup payez pas mon goût pour apprendre
un nouveau un nouveau tweak ce quelque
chose mais intelligemment joué par
quinze jours puis je parle avec le
lendemain c'est arrangé ça ça c'est
l'époque qui voulait plus que ses
travailleurs
tu parlais tantôt de leicester et quand
on a commencé à pouvoir suivre les gens
puissent voir le live stream est temps
que nous on regarde l'extérieur looking
end cpie d'étape toutes les plus beaux
spots au monde pour faire du snow autres
clips les plus belles montagnes du
voyage dans toutes les plus beaux les
plus belles places l'argent pour faire
ce est-ce que c'est comme tu le voyais
maintenant soulever ce qui c'est comme
tu le voyais quand a commencé ses katas
commencé à suivre les gars tu que tu te
fais créer un live tarata chasse c'est
tout comme tout l'imaginer mais en fait
ce qui est ce qui est spécial c'est que
mon rêve que j'avais quand j'avais 15
ans je me dis mon but c'est de voyager
le monde c'était 2
ne pas l'écrire de voir et m'ont fait
les jours c'était pas vraiment à devenir
super riches non plus à mon but j'ai tu
d'être les meilleurs on peut décemment
même c'est juste de la tôle ses seuls
paix puis c'est mon dans mon rêve à 15
ans mon but maintenant je pense alors
aujourd'hui c'était comme d'aller aux x
games
mais c'était même pas de faire un podium
et si c'était juste que voyager fois les
plus grosses compétences et flousta les
gens assis j'ai atteint mon rêve
puis quand je commence à m'entraîner
vraiment peau pendant deux ou trois ans
puis quand je les surpasser même temps
rêve a évolué avec le temps
chaque fois que tu te dis atteindre un
certain milestone 2 db je vise la
prochaine en france bien après c'était
je peux pas directement c'est à dire
c'est plus comme des objectifs pas après
passe muraille verte est comme réalisé
que je le vis encore aujourd'hui et
finalement c'est plus comme des
objectifs que je rajoute donc quand j'ai
commencé jean a failli podium mais la
précieuse bockel si je pourrai acheter
deux de plus à mon titre d'enfant puis
je me suis dit dans un coup d'inventer
un tweet loin d'être parmi ceux qui font
comme avant celle ci c'est fou donc j'ai
commencé à faire ce puits j'ai tripé
lathus l'adrénaline neuf fois quelque
chose qui était le seul sa part a essayé
plus la terrible de kawa c'est le
feeling extraordinaire dont j'ai trouvé
là dessus j'ai continué parce j'ai
inventé comme un 4/5 sow puis apprécier
les années paires sont arrivés c'est à
la fois c'est dans mon début les mêmes
horaires ça existait pas puis le sait
c'est arrivé en cours de chemin qu'on
avait la possibilité d'un epic une belle
opportunité travaux labour puis comme
apprécié des projets que ce soit
rachetée puisse elle-même depuis que
j'ai 18 ans et comme je me fais du
maître des objectifs de plus à la fin de
processus d'inventer une triste qu'on
parle de ça c'est fou le tx10 personne
n'a jamais fait ça mais j'imagine que
tout le monde a une idée de ckoi qui
m'attire ajoute maintenant un flip de
plus 38 ans 1 362 plus denses à 80 de
plus
mettez de pitcher désert puis de le
faire c'est notre contigent juste à
essayer des trucs en même temps tu te
plantes et même des centaines de fois
baptisé ce que comme ceux de 50 ans et
plus on sait tout un peu c'est quoi les
trucks sont pas faits tant qu'hôte
anciennement possible mais personne n'a
jamais cessé de la faucheuse qui étaient
les couilles assez grossier mais c'est
ça c'est ça qui est une scène métier
c'est pas juste avoir l'écouté sache que
tu vas faire contrôler tu as peur ou de
contrôler son stress l'anxiété faute sur
vraiment focus il faut que tu comprennes
les laitues exposition photos débat dans
les visualiser vraiment de haut à ziad
puis en fait de ma part dans les dix
premiers ce que j'ai inventé j'hésite
tout pas mal atterri en dedans de un ou
deux coups ah oui juste parce que j'ai
visualisé pendant des moore avant piste
est tellement clair dans ma tête que
c'était comme si je l'avais fait déjà
mille fois et puis c'est en fait un
psychologue sportif qui est jetée avec
depuis comme 4 5 ans puis memri me dis à
chaque fois que tu viennes jeudi
visualiser soit en tête 76 visualise
trois fois de suite c'est comme si notre
le faire trois fois 100 mètres je savais
vraiment au même site suffisent à l'iss
vraiment bien c'est vraiment de comme la
vraie pratique puis justement comme aimé
ce que j'ai inventé j'ai visualisé
tellement souvent tellement longtemps
que quand j'arrivais pour les faire se
faisait assez facilement il y en eut un
par contre que j'ai eu beaucoup de
misère
je suis c'est le dernier levier inventé
ça fait comme deleuze en outre le double
d'accès radio 14 puis lui en fait j'ai
eu la mesure parce que j'ai décidé que
j'allais faire cette rixe deux le matin
même jamais visualisé avant je n'avais
jamais vraiment pratiquée sa trampoline
ou autres donc se protéger en fait je
pense à un prix quasiment 10 11 coups le
faire parce que j'étais comme propre
répartis existons school que tic s'est
quand même dit son os coup est-ce que tu
tombes le web mais en fait c'était une
décision dont je pense aujourd'hui c'est
un petit peu dangereux condition celle
de partir un matin puis dire que je vais
gérer mon temps une boutique aujourd'hui
je vois ces autres j'imagine que la peur
peut pas faire partie de l'équation le
camp quand et pour y aller le 6
si tu as peur de rater ça tire opté tu
le feras paul fait moi je pense que dans
n'importe quoi dans la vie
c'est toujours bon d'avoir un petit peu
peur parce que si tu pars de rien c'est
là que tu fais des décisions stupides
c'est là qu'ils étaient en bas d'un pont
caisse beau essayer un tricks qui est
complètement foot et je pensais l'avoir
juste un petit peu de parents c'est
parfait parce que ça va garder ton focus
à votre garder allumée puis ça va garder
je te vends tes sens tu te caches dans
les airs en snowboard sa gamme essence
encore plus justement allumés a réussi
mais le tchèque ce parce que c'était
vraiment pas peur de rien trop pro focus
être pas concentré puis c'est là que les
blessures que va respecter d'avoir un
petit peu pas de santé juste ton moqueur
kibo acheté une petite forme au chou
c'est parfait quand quand était
quelqu'un comme toi tu est vraiment une
conscience de ton corps dans l'espace
dans leur corrige mois sur le tronc la
perception que j'ai c'est que les
snowboardeurs puis les gens qui font du
sport extrême de haut niveau avec des
tricks pitou c'est rare que tu des
calices comme un amateur le thé dansant
sous mais donc mettons des heures que tu
sens que tu es pendre n 2 lundi le
tchèque
j'imagine que vous avez des réflexes qui
vous permettent de poche juste tomber
même le coup tout croche a peur de lui
pour être vraiment écouté on a fait des
millions de sow fait qu' on est habitué
d'être dans les airs puis surtout moi
plus je viens du québec durant un été
chez beaucoup de trampoline dans leurs
enfants pauline jetons isère encore plus
souvent que sur la montagne puis le bus
a toujours été le plus confortable
possible puis souvent fait qu'en
quelques tricks va pas marcher
on le sait de suite comme à la fin de ce
ou quatre kits le sautier de ce fait tu
le sais je suis gentil donnant à ces
disciplines craxi john petit chien
confortable du 6ème temps je m'en avoir
fait un triple puis le décident ce
qu'ils en marche pour bâtir et je veux
tu t'ouvres et puis je vois le finir en
deux jours attiré par et puis sinon tant
les artistes continuent à y aller moi en
chaque flip ou à chaque rotation je
regarde toujours du jeu c'est la hauteur
que je suis je sais mais reste combien
de temps environ puis le je vois d'ici
dans les airs qui je continue sa marche
bien
ou et ça marche pas mais je vais ouvrir
puis au lieu de la foire maintenant 1440
mais la fin mai 81 en place que cela
nous arrive de tomber aussi mais on a
appris à tomber le temps aux six mois ce
sera pas tombé du crush 3d sexy ventiler
le boire votre champ premier l'impact
sur les jambes peu après sur votre dos
ou le 20 mai salle amortissez fumant ce
que votre cerveau calculé l'annoncé sans
rire le thème le dit et on met en quête
fait 1-1 bégué commente seconde était
désert je pensais au tour de 2.6 2.8
puis mettons les sous les plus extrêmes
que tu peux faire le mettons pour
quelqu'un connait 0 sur le coma comment
de philippe plus forte
comment de tous on trouve un petit peu
fermé tant belle allée avec les plus
grosses augmenté fadasse et des cadres
1800 moi je n'ai pas encore appris ces
lieux mais pour moi c'est un trip 1800
hockey fait que ce facto trop philippe
sur trois mois avec 5800 de
l'hydratation shit sa semaine en crise
et a même pas trop ça c'est fou mais
c'est sûr que c'est c'est eh c'est sûr
que tout ceci est injuste instinctif
maintenant les deux pôles tendance n'est
pas le temps de calculer les tirs
continuent c'est le sujet ça fait partie
comme est ce que c'est et arrivée de ta
carrière professionnelle de est-ce que
tu des des blessures liées à une chute
qui t'ont mis hors circuit pendant du
temps où tout le temps et écarts de
gérer seul non en fait
en fait moi quand j'avais justement 15
ans je te manges tomber je suis des fois
j'avais mal au dos pendant trois
semaines puis je compte s'en fasse le
moins de pareille matière notamment au
dos pendant trois semaines c'est pas
très bon puis c'est là que j'ai
découvert que ce qui protège nos assez
nos muscles fait que d'aller au gym
c'est une bonne chose pas pour devenir
le plus fort ou pour sauter plus haut
c'est vraiment pour les blessures qui
ont affecté je serai beaucoup de com
autour des autos des genoux autour des
ports de dislocation passé donc je
pensais vraiment important d'avoir des
bons muscles pour pour sauver nos os
puis depuis que je m'entraîne jamais
majeures jo il est petit accrochage je
me suis cassé le scaphoïde
quand j'avais comme 17 ans puis sinon la
blessure en fait qui a été la paix pour
moi c'est dans mes débuts j'avais de la
misère à landing fait que j'allais pas
assez vite puis souvent trop souvent le
cas les blogs
puis j'ai eu une mais deux talons son
agresseur bruce fils comme chez les
bleus à l'intérieur de ses talons - à
l'intérieur de tes talons puis je t'aime
je m'étais juste tombé le pouls sur le
pelouse mais comme dit ces deux noms de
30 pieds d'un double bang bang bang ses
talons puis le pendant trois mois de
temps je pourrai être pu mettre mes
talons je marchais trossat point de mire
puis images dans mes débuts les
personnes gay avec les trois banques
c'est là mes débuts durant la mieux la
saison je pouvais pas me permettre de
manquer une saison un fait qui ne
concerne encore la compétition pareille
puis le sais tu qui parce que toutes les
sauces et choisit fait toujours
atterrissent sa points des autres sinon
le j'avais envie de doublé de maxime a
fait ça a été quand même à plus et
blessures
imagine sur ma gêne geste c'était
bizarre imagine le choc d'atterrir même
sur du plus tabou puis quand même temps
cet hiver j'ai une autre chute with ging
justement c'était comme le 26 et 27
janvier
encore une fois je tombais avant les
avants de landing puis je vais cibler
c'est justement à la cheville gauche
je me suis étiré des ligaments puis et
tout l'hiver j'ai mal à ma cheville
je me suis fait taper tout l'hiver mais
en fait qu'un petit cage un problème et
c'est quand tu es dans minute à saison
le choix puis puis comme le aujourd'hui
le ça va super bien j'ai pas de problème
mais titres clés rsa saison j'aime un
physio qui me fait ch à nouveau puis on
a réussi à passer à la saison j'ai
réussi à gagner d'autres compétences a
bien été mais c'est sur qui on est quand
même des blessures de temps en temps
quand même maintenant tu t'entraînes par
jour par semaine
samak watts ça c'est une question je me
fais souvent posée puis je sais qu'on
peut on seulement comment répondre en
fait ça dépend surtout la météo
parce que je m'entraîne au sénégal est
ici plus belle jambe aux pauvres vous
avez pas la météo même si j'essaie d'y
aller comme environ trois fois semaine
puis sinon la leo jim trois semaines
aussi c'est pas mal c'est que ça se
passe mais c'est à travers ce jeu tant
fait juste une personne qui aime se
faire beaucoup de sport fait que je joue
beaucoup au tennis je fais dit le
montant est mon chien fait je montre mon
à 2 fois semaine aussi j'ai vu une vidéo
et wes idée semblait déjà très j'imagine
que toujours eu l'appel l'adrénaline
lorsque je vois la vidéo que partager
sur ton instagram de trucs des scènes je
te fais du vélo de montagne dans un
trailer mais comme ça va packing pisser
salaires qui ce malheureux java fort que
moi je crie ses deux bras le torse
ouais moi en fait les sports qui nous
donne un besoin de rallye j'adore ce que
je savais faire du rafting à sympa c'est
arrivé à rouge billetterie piste a
parfois tu arrives dans les rapides dans
les chips et kaoua s'écoule vers le
montant de ma fenêtre et il ya même des
pistes des idées déco mais dix vingt
pieds puis je m'ennuie là-dessus pichot
pc c'est vraiment une parenthèse à faire
des trucs descente qui vont me permettre
d'être transféré dans la vision pitt est
jo à être ces informations totalement
s'est vraiment passé au titre de la base
à prendre mais après c'est le feeling de
la vitesse leighlin car après justement
un saut en vélo c'est la même vitesse
que je l'aï appris quand même assez vite
fait que ça a été bien mais au lieu
d'être sur un vélo des heures d'écouté
un petit peu croche au début les goûts
mais avec le talent
la preuve il ya dessus team et on a tant
parlé des tricks le toujours à inventer
nouvelle crise pourrait pousser les
sports hamane et deux passes
forcément il va avoir une limitation non
non il faut toujours avoir des nouveaux
tricks plus extrêmes matin de choses qui
n est pas fini non non non puis toi
mettons le pour le béton qu'on parle de
la suite des choses le tout parce que tu
prévois encore faire ce long temps t'es
quoi tu sais que tu pleures mais
vraiment pour donner à l'autre question
c'est si jamais on dirait que tu vois
c'est fini quand c'est des choses qui
sont inatteignables pour nous autres on
est il plus de 130 puisque tu es
meilleur dans ce que tu fais plus qu il
noté niable des fois devient finalement
fait que
c'est ce que n'importe quel facile dans
la vie de chaque photo est bien meilleur
à quelque chose j'ai toujours des portes
qui s'ouvrent puisse elle-même que le
snowboard c'est la même affaire enfoncé
chaque truc ce qu'on fait au début il ya
un ton retourne que vingt ans en arrière
les sauts étaient de la même grandeur
qu'aujourd'hui les choses un peu plus
gros mois c'était il ya vingt ans des
doubles ça existait même pot dont dix
compagnies quadruples 1800 puis je te
dis qu'on parle du goût de l'époque tel
succès c'est dans le temps le dos voûté
car les pif ans a pas de bon ces écoutes
le sport il a évolué ça c'est vraiment
fou à si peu de temps c'est vraiment
quelque chose fait qu'il passe ça va
continuer encore voir des dessins qui
publie des dessins tube ce ça commence
c'est parce que tu sais qu'une rotation
complet c'est quand même beau coup à
jouer alors tu es faut que tu rajoutes
20% faut que tu squeeze 20% dans le même
temps soit atteint d'ici quelques années
probablement fait pour moi je veux un
peu mon but demeurant le sait pas encore
mais il ya plein d'autres façons de
progresser sport que ce soit un nouveau
gr bout où je sais que créatif avec avec
d'autres manoeuvres comme justement il
ya trois ans quand je veux me donner
toutes les gemmes artistes ont un double
que j'ai rajouté 1 300 dedans mais que
personne n'avait jamais fait dans
l'histoire fait que dans les double
encore des choses à aller plus les
portes d'entrée flutie fait il n'est pas
juste que me rends chez les flics défilé
petit il ya aussi d'autres avenues puis
j'essaie de me concentrer un peu plus là
dedans parce que je trouve justement si
on a tellement comme foxy sûr apprendre
et triple plomb ordinaire quadruples
mais on se trouve des étapes un peu le
fait qu'ils mangent et celle de cameron
est un mariage d'aller pousser un peu
plus les autres ces malades puis pour
pour faire suite à l'autre question de
dire toi combien de temps tu dois faire
cinq ans est ce que tu sens que les
capacités physiques pour être limitée
éventuellement si avec l'âge j'ai tout
de suite le mais est ce que tu sens que
c'est une possibilité
un pas du tout mon corps en ce moment je
suis à chaque année je me sens plus fort
c'est que en ce moment je suis encore
plus fort que j'étais leader en inde
avant donc pour sûr je pense pas qu'un
problème même charnois été comme 32 33
puits
je pense même son fils du plus fort que
jamais et est maintenant à droite de
loin sont son 8 ème siècle avec des
zones et des olympiques les jeux
olympiques chan obaka mario pas de paris
a encore et il ya comme un hic comme est
revenue le haut top 100 et après avoir
un peu disparu comme le meilleur c'est
cheap à saïfi comme 4e quatrième aux
jeux olympiques performe
mais c'est après vente à questions mon
but s'en vient de plus en plus défini
mais y est pas encore c'est encore flou
dans ma tête c'est en fait depuis que
j'ai comme 18 ans qui continue c'est
quand même année après année ils jamais
je focus trop loin d'avant médecins à
mettre mon idée floue en ce moment c'est
de concert pour la compétition c'est sûr
d'ailleurs aux prochains jeux olympiques
et dans deux hivers très en chine un
aqueduc encore puis dans le fond
après si ça serait peut-être de faire
comme un ou deux encore de combien gex
games puis 26 29
je pense comme arrêter la compétition
pour de bon j'aime encore ce
compétitionner mais si ça fait quand
même déjà dix ans que je fais ça donc
j'ai juste besoin d'un peu plus encore
puis les olympiques j'ai pas encore
gagné la médaille d'or que celui ci
comme un mini bus et sur mes concerts la
compétition
puis après ça je me transfère et
peut-être dans le film ming un peu plus
loin parce que aussi comme tout cet
aspect là nos sports et donc falloir
faire leur carrière juste en faisant du
film puissant compétition donc j'ai
commencé à faire du bac 15 juillet 2 1
puis le geste comme maître d'oeuvre de
plus en plus fait que je montre labo
avec mon ski doo shakespeare avec mon
père mon ski 12 puis je laisse mon pick
up la batterie voix puis entre les
voyages tient largement voilà beau jeu
facebook je suis et puis je filme pas
encore on ne peut pas tout le temps pour
nous ici commence écoute banquet du bac
s et en dehors des pistes de ski dans
les montagnes on m'a souvent les vidéos
que tu vois là milieu de nulle part le
petit diminue pas en montagne au ski doo
puis le cap titre c'est comme les
panoplies de la montagne à l'infini puis
le mois gérer des cendres le petit
montant ski-doo puis le sait ou
sexuelles
moi j'ai beaucoup de sahraouis cela donc
alentours de wisques lieu pleine
montagne fils on se promène là dedans
puis s'il y en a d'autres qui qui vont
écoper aussi j'ai fait ça aussi c'est
aussi un peu plus dispendieux
c'est le fameux mais ça va être
difficile mentalement fait d'europe et
le plus c'est quand même qu'ils
descendent est très très très rare c'est
le bac contre lui puis dans le fond ils
ont reconstruit des sceaux puis au ce
des drops puis l'ont fait les tuer que
c'est en fait tout et tout ce que je
fais en compétition ou dans les parcs à
neige on transfère sur dandy et les
aspects naturels
ça donne des instituts c'est exactement
puis le tuer les vidéos actuels mais sur
youtube où du fait des films puisque
c'est comme un autre je t'aime ma
carrière fait que mon bus comme de
m'initier en ce moment puis dans comme 3
3 4 ans quand je finis par la
compétition belge vous transférez la
dame doit être déjà pris à comme partie
des projets soit être pourquoi mais deux
trois ans puis après le dessus je pense
que je vais me taire peut-être là qu'il
a dedans puis avoir vu au québec serait
en quelque chose que j'ai
que j'ai très hâte d'avoir une vie
normale où elle vit normalement je fasse
même hissé sur mathieu voyager autant
que je fais puis c'est quand même et ça
prend beaucoup d'énergie de plus je
m'entraîne à l'année longue
donc c'est ça qui était d'avoir un peu
plus de stabilité
c'est quelque chose qui m'intéresse
c'est un jour pas de suite mais un jour
donc donc j'envisage comme dans mon
début trentaine de comme commence à
ralentir les choses franchement j'ai
commencé tranquillement comme à m'ouvrir
des portes pour après j'ai pas envie
d'arrêter
qu'est ce que je fais il faut que j'ai
rien puisque je venais de commencer à
comme préparer mon après-carrière un
enfant puis j'ai toujours eu un peu
l'entrepreneur dans le mois prémat
maquillage est toujours géré de a à z
c'est une carrière d'entrepreneur
témoignages on entre chez moi qui dis si
de quelconques et que chez ces mots qui
vomit l'avion c'est moi qui bloque les
affaires donc j'essaie vraiment quelque
chose qui qui qui m'allume gérer c'est
drôle ça parce que je sais pas ce que je
te coupe mais juste pour là dessus
ferrals à présent c'est quelque chose
qui est propre
c'est juste qu'à marquer mais tout a
commencé ça va de l'a13 autodidacte que
je regarde des vidéos puis je vaux parc
puis j'essaie les affaires puis je pars
j'avais vu juste en même temps qu'ils
avaient écrit aux attentes coacher pour
elle j'ai vu que des courtiers intel
jeudi mme courchesne à 91 fait que cindy
qui a fait du sport mais qui fait la
natation c'est que mes 30 ans inclus pis
toutes les décisions sont prises pour
toi puisque pas toi qui beau petit
billet d'avion au niveau des
compétitions puis c'est vraiment spécial
montrer qu'il ya de plus en plus une
structure un genre de cadre pour les
jeunes est encore un peu frustré mais en
fait c'est très structuré puis avec
l'équipe nationale justement un
tourbillon les coaches puis il décède et
vous relâcher mon frère puis sont très
encadrés
sans le fond mais ce qu'avaient ces
structures là que tout commence et être
la possibilité de faire ce mois il y
avait ce puits en fait au début avant
set je savais ce sens les journaux aussi
jean paris mais justement l'équipe
nationale comme m'obliger à m'entraîner
avec les autres n'est obligé de suivre
leur structure le marché connaît ça
marche pas le mot je fais mes affaires
puis mais à force ça va bien je suis mon
propre
c'était puis fait que j'avais quitté
l'équipe nationale à cause de ça puis le
finalement je m'étais qualifié présent
et peel off ne mâche revenu puis le long
temps superbe remontée
il n'y a pas de problème mais je fais ma
part mon côté puis mosa marche pas bien
de même puis on doit qui donc en 4 une
passion date à bouaké quant aux
toilettes comme qui dit coiffeur sa
salle enlève la passion ça enlève le fon
un peu puis m'a dit j'ai quand même mes
coaches bakhti que j'engage moi même
mais c'est moi qui ai décidé d engager
depuis le fait que ça vienne de moi même
dit ils sont quand même autour de moi
petit une dirige quand même mais mais
c'est comme si ma décision fait comme
qui me dit de faire n'importe quoi comme
acquis le fait que son résultat au stade
décision a très exactement
donc je les écoute j'ai du fun à les
écouter mais mes deux enfants font des
coiffeurs par quelqu'un que j'ai pas
décidé notamment de travailler avec ben
pour moi ça marche pas dans ma tête
c'est fou on en avait reçus félix aujali
a siem puis lui est il aussi fait son
enfant ils ont propre boss s'y engage
ses cols c'est lui qui engage toute son
équipe
et puis j'ai l'impression qu'il ya une
réelle réflexion à avoir sur les sports
encadrés ou est-ce que tu as
l'impression que tu dois faire c'est la
décision ne revient pas à toile puis là
c'est sûr que tu perds le plaisir de le
faire des travaux toi qui décide de le
faire puisque tu peux nous mettons je
pleure parce exane et que je
m'entraînais pis le pourquoi que je
faisais certaines affaires j'en avais
aucune des comptes l'elysée festif et
sur mes sites de pau s'est passé que
l'objectif sais pas pourquoi tu fais ce
pic est ce que ça va être apportée je
vais pas avec la même rigueur par une
patiente sûre que ce soit c'est aussi
tout le temps été effectué dans le fond
c'est surtout c'est ton régime
d'entraînement puisque tu fais est sa
fenêtre toile finalement intéressant
vous savez ça nous tue le temps d'aller
vous savez à quoi ça servait tout les
enfants que tu faisais heureusement puis
au delà il m'a fait que celle enfin j'ai
quand même été mon beau propose depuis
le début puis j'ai vraiment sens dans
deux mois puis dans son le côté
entreprend entreprendre puis les enfants
pourront pour l'après carrière dans le
fond j'ai décidé de commencer à investir
dans l'immobilier d'ouvrir un restaurant
de partir au projet dont je commence
tranquillement comme placer mes quatre
pour après appuyé sur des avenues que
j'adore j'ai des bons pas retenu la
dedans puis ils m'apprennent le site du
pin à faire [ __ ] j'ai réalisé aussi
avec le temps avec mes voyages manger
fait que les contacts c'est fou comment
t'es tu apprends avec son ex comme
l'école c'est de rencontrer du monde à
travers la planète et de cultures
différentes business comment ça marche
puis j'ai tellement
j'ai vraiment pris un gros bagage avec
moi depuis dix ans puis le jeu commence
à me sentais prêt comme je t'aime à
mettre ce comme au terrain puis commence
à ma musique tout ce que j'ai appris
c'est quoi les c'est quoi les plus
belles places au site et à l'est par le
snowboard
j'ai je dirais que la nouvelle zélande
qui est vraiment très très très beau
pays
une des landes ont des gros glacier la
grosse montagne
je pense que c'est des glaciers mais il
ya beaucoup montagne de neige sont
justement durant l'hiver sur l'île du bo
puis sinon en suisse
associer des glaciers je vois toujours
le mode octobre puis c'est vraiment une
place extraordinaire
tout ce qu'ont certaines s'appelle ça se
fait c'est un petit village comme à
whistler où tremblent en fait y'a pas de
tout puis la console vient comme dans le
milieu du vie du village au mois
d'octobre de gazole et les les conifères
commence à changer de couleur peut plus
être gracié en eau que l'on descend à
hbo après avoir fait de nombreux
terrains de tennis on joue au tennis la
même journée c'est vraiment c'est
incroyable et montagne c'est vraiment
lui coûter matin alors que c'est très
beau ça en terme de beauté ce long terme
de culture judéo japon 3 3 ou 4 fois
j'ai eu beaucoup plus à deux japonais
quand même ouais puis sont extrêmement
bon sens très très bien encadré la
beauce eeb puis c'est tantôt je te
disais qu'il y ait au canada on est
seulement un bail est ici puis la bouche
pas sérieusement 5,6 lambert feh kessé
dont ils sont sont vraiment bien encadré
puis ils sont très très bons longs
l'ayant les voies ouais ouais puisse
j'imagine c'est une nouveau un peu la
boue ont été plus tard un peu sur le sur
le trend en fait l'ailé l'airbag la
beauce affectueusement je pense disant
qu'ils ont vaincus puis le tour dans la
com découvrir jusqu'à très émetteurs la
culture du snowboard ça fait tilt
longtemps autant qui met tant aux états
unis qu'en fin en août
ah ouais ça fait très longtemps un vrai
qu'il fait là là bas en fait au japon et
dans les montagnes
extraordinaire pour faire la planche la
poudreuse a pu enchaîner je pense une
des meilleures places dans le monde
pourrait dès la poudre reçoit un salaire
salalah d'humeur sentiment au monde de
la poudreuse joe wright personnage paul
d'en face depuis un an c'est vraiment un
bon fils et ses coups les plus hauts en
altitude où est ce que tu te rendes
émeutes ont l'appui aux attitudes c'est
au colorado en fait que les x games
c'est justement quelque chose qui rend
la tâche un peu plus difficile compliqué
parce qu'on est à douze mille pieds
d'altitude qui pendant une semaine de
temps donc les témoins des globules
blancs rouges dentressangle et 2 puis ça
fait qui est déshydratée extraits cités
plus vite essoufflé avant et après pour
les bébés c'est un sou mais seul
obstacle si on a quand même 4 4l avec le
site jugé impressionnant comme 3,4 saut
ça dure et on va de 50 secondes
la descente d'une minute et 4 arrivant
bolt et était soufflé le puits même des
fois entre les sièges qu'on me tue plus
étourdis un pur puis faut quand même
trouver une façon de s'hydrater fait que
moi je bois beaucoup d'eau avec je mets
du dans la peau des électrolytes puis je
bois centre chaque descente puis ça m je
bois pas d'alcool du tout de la semaine
passée de mode et kaffrine non plus fait
que je prends des café décaféiné
passelac affine sa déshydrate aussi donc
il faut vraiment faire attention la bo
parce que ça m'est déjà arrivé d
déshydraté le pilote a mentionné un tour
dit voir beaucoup y et puis même mais
ton juste aller au pérou le titre des
montagnes la burqa mais le modèle sous
ses pieds ptc poteau maquillage pareil
ligne alexis met à vomir l'inquiète
c'est vraiment le cinéma grande avance
pour s'acclimater ou mais également
parce que si nous combattons hiver c'est
vraiment bac à bac puis dans le fond
avant les risques un aspect toujours en
suisse la semaine d'avant
donc on voyage le dimanche puis des fois
je reviens au québec une journée
plusieurs portes suite au colorado qui
est chanté oh comme c'est ce que tu sens
une différence dans la résistance de
leur présence ou s'impose passé importe
imposant pour que tu le sens
non moi j'avais même pensé à se balader
plus minces le comme les parties de la
tête de sens mais mais mais je suis pro
ne manquez pas assez ou encore pour le
sang sur les mains jointes
ces fous pareils évidemment je veux
qu'on parle un peu de temps de ta
maladie et dernière en éclats dernières
années c'est l'histoire la plus in scène
du sport j'entendais un après tu as ta
victoire selon x games ou est-ce que tu
venais vaincre le cancer ou est-ce que
l'annonceur dit il n'ya rien de plus
cliché que jose que je vais dire là
c'est extrêmement cliché mais je m'en
fous lgv à dire quand même
you can not right there c'est une
histoire hollywoodienne que tu vois
c'est un film qui fait wayne fowkes
dalphond d'alphonse comment est ce qu a
appris que pour quelle raison ce qui est
un délit de flirt choqué au début tu
sais comment c'est arrivé
commencent à arriver dans le fond à
partir du mois de mai pourrait septembre
2018 en 2018
je commence à me gratter un peu
l'apothéose gratter qui sera noir
invitée par marc rating s'allume pas
trop long un métier à manier comme je me
grattais vraiment
jusqu'aux un déplacement mabhouh était
vraiment le sèche dans ok mathis a
encore samalut mais pas vraiment des
affaires s'est plus ou mois de jeu
passée début novembre
j'ai remarqué 2 cuil un matin je me
regarde pas dans le miroir tous les
jours je me lève le matin je mariage
puis j'avais une bosse dans mon cou une
bosse quand même c'est que une fois
j'avais une fois j'avais remarqué je
voyage souvent joué juste
je me rappelle ma route j aime puis le
jeu montre à mon coach plaisir avant
tout une bosse et puis même si sedan
face à montguyon et à enfler dans le
fond puis normalement mais ganglions il
y en a toujours qui te manque un jour
avant grippe suivante je le sens qu'un
euro sans offrir des tribunes en tant
qu'adjoint de grippe mais là ça faisait
trois semaines puis elle pas de dire
j'avais rien fait les choses comme je
commence à trouver ça bizarre un peu
puis le jeter en voyage manche j'étais
en train de franck option en chine en
fait j'étais yuko avant avant sur
demande à la chine fait que je me suis
dit en revenant la chine je dois aller
tchéquie voir le docteur vous sentez
plus faibles ou même peut aucunement
aucunement puis souhaite une chose que
tout le monde réagit différemment mais
était jugée en retrait du monde qui ont
eu la main quand ça que moi [ __ ] et les
autres il sentait faible y avait des
histoires la nuit tout seul puis moi
j'avais vraiment aucun symptôme apport
de me gratter la peau puis c'est tout et
je te énergie que je te le donc là je
vais avoir mon médecin de famille pas
docteur mais au moment de sa famille
puis le il a peut-être suffi à regarder
ce puits l'amdi si bel après midi en
france et trois options d oxyde money
souci quelque chose de banal simplement
où ça près de cancer quand j'ai entendu
ça mérite quand même un peu comme comme
frappée puis
absolument dans mon char tu le sais pas
pourquoi mais quand dans mon feeling
j'avais comme un feeling ça me fait un
tube puis j'ai quand même versé une
coupe de la main peu l'amour choc puis
après ça j'ai eu du mal biopsie qui
était la semaine suivante
cette étoffe encore parce que moi j'ai
jamais manquer de compétition dans toute
ma vie la semaine suivante c'était le
doubs tour que j'avais gagné pour la
première fois de l'année d'avant rejeté
comme le champion depuis le chalet comme
une grosse compétition
les x games c'est la deuxième fois que
la meute avait eu les résultats ou pas
encore
non c'est donc manquer tu manques la
commission pour aller faire des biopsies
exactement puis dans le fond moti
j'essaie de toucher la biopsie après la
compétition était dans ma tactique à
geoffrey une semaine plus tard si je
vais faire la compétition métiers
l'adaptation 26 femmes et des crèmes ou
chez moi j'ai récemment fait qu'après
sujets comme la coupe d'europe c'est
comme ça c'est tout de même fait que le
feeling comme sa grande soeur va donc je
défends la biopsie
puis une semaine après puis les enfants
quand ils en sont pris comme un brigand
guillon qui avait ici le puy - en fait
mon beau frère il est docteur puis lui
m'avait dit que justement quand le
docteur aliev fin de quelque chose il
voit de suite c'est un cancer
théoriquement son compositeur le dit pas
c'est pas ton médecin c'est plus mon
médecin de famille je veux te dire ou
l'autre docteur l'hôpital il faut que le
rapport est fait mais al assad est
réveillé il vient me voir et me dis donc
ça s'est bien passé
fatigué soulagé dit ce jeudi et jusqu'à
sa démission c'est pas encore le gérant
estime cancer je sais que si je suis
appelé c'est après ça j'ai dit je sais
que jacques disponibles et utopie pillay
mais le com mais comme il sait immédiate
et quand ça fait juste aller comme ça
allait passer mais ça c'est une nouvelle
j'ai mis des cas mais mais c'est qu'en
deux semaines avancent comme je
commençais déjà à me préparer ça mais
jamais comme frappés john fait ça mais
comme ça me potel m'a frappé page et
servir des gets c'était juste une
confirmation très apprécié c'est de
savoir quelqu'un c'est lui le jeu déçu
le 23 décembre le 21 décembre après
fille
mais quand tu entends ces mots le temps
tu te prépares et déjà mais qu'ils
entendent le mot ce qu'est ce que ça
fait ben c'est ce qui attire les mots
cancers
j'entends des mots quand ces attentats
c'est très mal classés comme teymour
fait qui est un beau symbole fort en
tant que pilote c'est que de sedan toit
puis moi c'était juste et je me
regardais mon corps qui sait j'ai
regardé mon gars ils ont chacun mis à
decroix qui pousse dans mon corps qui
qu'ils vont me tuer tient comme bhutto
tuée
j'ai quand même joué cette horreur je
t'ai pas vraiment très très familier
avec avec le cancer non plus en fait
j'ai un ami qui est le cancer 2 avant
moi qui fait que j'ai comme un prix un
peu attristé quoi la chimio tout ça mais
pas nécessairement comme plus plus en
détail de ce fait je serais pas
nécessairement ces séquences alain pitié
à voir se jeter un peu comme ignorant au
début j'ai jamais vraiment eu peur de
mourir ça comme jamais vraiment été
encore une fois une option rejetée car
pour battre mais ce qui était vraiment
dur à digérer pour moi c'était
certainement qu'ils m'ont nivard au
complet moi je crois que c'est juste
comme carrière caillage que je manque
que je monte mon univers complexe comme
dans les moeurs année puis comme ça me
fait vraiment chier de passer
automatiquement saison si j'en saurai un
peu plus il est arrivé au mois deux afin
de faciliter un peu plus planifiés
tellement qu'au début je disais ma
docteur au moins tu y es sétif c'est ce
que j'ai fait au moins les x games qui
étaient comme à trois semaines du
[Rires]
primitif et je me sente énergie que je
me sentais normal si j'avais pas de
symptômes mais c'est là que les âmes
comme fabien peu plus et comédie hameedi
ami dit pauvre tu peux y aller tu peux
les faire a dit le cancer apparemment
pas tendre au 6e rang dans trois
semaines soit pas trop faire une grosse
différence au niveau de la masse jeu ça
va continuer métier ça vas tu faire une
différence peut-être pas mais a dit
c'est sûr que plus l'état tente le plus
tôt tu le prends plus que cette chance
de mourir les gens me disaient mais
comme frapper jusqu'à moi je vous dis
pas plus de chance en amour et copines
au nom de téléphone mais vivre
j'entendais ton coach qui disait que
quelqu'un qui a appris la nouvelle tutsi
dirigée sur la flore qui ont quand c'est
l'hiver c'était le compétitions telles
conditions pis lui dis dans ma tête
j'étais en train de pleurer dans ma tête
c'est comme arrête de me parler des
compétitions le de quoi tu parles même
puis ça c'est pour pour l'entourage
cette offre cette nouvelle le tueur soit
sur puis le en même temps de voir ta
réaction à toi de faire à ce site est un
obstacle qu'ont vos gants convaincre
faites attention à comment on organise
ma carrière après ceux qui tentent au
quotidien
j'en prends moi qui pourrait plus jamais
faire est aubois n'ont vu juste on veut
pas que ce qui convenait après l'ipod
troubles voilà ça quand même bon on a
dans ma route j'avais enlevé six mois
contre ce n'était pas une option de
porter à le battre mais mais il était
enfant j'étais vraiment foxes sur ma
carrière parce que si c'est en fait
toute ma vie c'était ma carrière ça
faisait comme une enfant de 10 ans que
je vis ici depuis c'était comme la seule
chose que je connaissais c'était ma
carrière c'est ce qui la suspectaient
que la première fois qu'il m'arrive je
montre ma saison jusqu'au bout et ça me
fera boule si ça fait dix ans que chef
de la fin de saison voyager le monde
puis d'avoir la star le fou puis le four
chaud sur un lit d'hôpital dans ce mode
tant que ouais c'est sûr que ça allait
me chercher là pour avoir ma vie normale
de faire ma saison pis ma carrière ça se
passe m'intéresse ma passion je dis
toujours qu'il y avait six comme pour
moi ce que t'en sais que c'est sûr que
c'était ma passion je pense en premier
ça l'affecté c'est que ces six beaucoup
de si mais c'est sûr que ça met ton
genre je regarde aujourd'hui d'un autre
angle de vue après avoir passé après les
après traitement tout ce que je me lève
aucune des steaks ou à la chimio tout ce
qu'un quand j'étais au débuter bientôt
lagarde sont aujourd'hui puisque c'est
sûr que j'attaque reçu d'une différentes
façons de ses puits tgc comme j'étais
justement c'est la seule fois que je
pensais avant c'est que ma carrière ma
passion puis y'a rien d'autre puis
aujourd'hui je suis juste une personne
complètement sûr que ça les gens parce
que je jouais la vie vraiment d'un autre
angle encore faux pas parce que j'ai eu
peur de mourir
je pense vraiment je le fais de la shdm
ou tard épices comme stenio vraiment
beaucoup prêté un gros diamant pendant
six mois temps constamment de ce type au
mit à chaque jour puis s'est pas fait
c'est juste pour le fun vivent carrément
c1 six mois que je te pas envie de vivre
puis c'est sa fille qui te fait réaliser
après ça comment la vie est belle si le
pouvoir de pouvoir pour vous mais à
chaque jour main pour bien filer le pour
faire des sports pour faire ce que tu
veux après sur t'apprécie la vie encore
beaucoup plus fin que s'est fixé pas par
peur de mourir mais juste parce que tu
vis vraiment l'enfer plus tard santé
comment profiter aux bottines avec une
personne vous
coût plus ouverte qu'à 20 puis j'adore
ce jeu j'ai toujours tu es toujours
adoré en fait d'explorer les ont jeté un
peu plus inconfortable puis le
aujourd'hui le depuis a fait comme si
cette mort les explore la fonte font que
ce soit même dans la bouffe aventis
jamais prises du kid ni les champignons
les olives le fait de manger des gc ca
ou veut plus aujourd'hui disons au mof
quelque chose avec les champignons tipi
je vois le prendre à le manger comme si
paris m'était public un très bon jeu
vraiment moins compliqué qu'avant chi
puis la vie est comme plus simple puis
jeu plus physique doing avant justement
comme je planifiais turquie comme je
demandais des xavi comme jamais comme je
le disais tantôt je n'ai fait que mon
long long long terme métier mais ton
durant mon année je savais à chaque jour
déjà les forêts et puis je vais toujours
dans le futur je te motive je vais
toujours comme deux trois semaines en
avance je t'ai pas capable de vivre le
moment présent et sam un apport c'est
sûr que quand je fais mon snow bros cash
game jam c'est sûr je suis fidèle aux à
bat yam et ont jeté un sort aux équipes
votre cuzance je peux accepter des amis
et ma tête était jamais focus une moment
puis mais l'homme et non celui justement
le moment présent comme je vous parle ce
moment puis je pense pour hadopi le
puits
j'adore c'est quelque chose c'est un
feeling incroyable puis je suis content
en fait que j'ai réussi à découvrir
c'est vraiment fou ce qu'une expérience
aux mêmes peu peu changé dans une
personne si je m'imagine juste avec tes
relations avec les autres thématiques ta
famille avec les gens proches de toi le
petit des relations des fois on a
dépensé pour acquis par exemple mais le
secon qui non le tuer les gens mais non
c'est sûr le carcan du poste proche de
mais pas pour des projets mettront ce
que je dis mais je ne fais plus
attention rien d'acquis dans la vie que
sur n'importe quoi après marié puis
c'est ça justement qui te fait apprécier
les moments encore plus j'ai vu une
photo de toi pendant le traitement des
de kim hyo pitié n'avait pas fière
allure mais des moments où est-ce
quelqu'un s'était tu te décourager ou
dans la tête c'est elle est tout le
temps sortir de dessous
c'est au début me jeter
après trois mois vomir tout les jours
puis a perdu quoi puis bâti les
prochaines semaines sally pas un
traitement
je savais pas de quoi vraiment en fait
il m'avait donné une pile de livres de
livres à léo des bulles sur les
traitements comment ça se passe avec
qualcomm tease effets secondaires tout
ce mois j'ai utilisé puis je trouvais
leur jeter ma comme ça fasse comme sorti
de ma zone de confort
de quoi on plante en aiguille le puits
il faudrait site pendant trois heures de
temps pire des poches de sang vont
d'amorçage connaissais rien suffit comme
elecom trois-quatre premiers coups de
coeur japonais ce qui se passe est jetée
comme je déconne enfin je n'ai pas
préparé et puis en fait j'étais contente
pour préparer par si j'arrêtais préparé
mais j'ai retrouvé ce encore plus dur au
début tu es comme j'apprenais au début
ce qui ce possible ça me permet en fait
qu'un mec comme 34.1 traitement se fasse
plus facilement parce que j'apprenais
retient la presse après le quatrième je
commençais ça commençait à être tous
routinier un peu plus stressé je savais
à quoi m'attendre je savais que de plus
en plus c'est en fait le moins que temps
de récupérer avant l'autre fait de plus
en plus que tu filmes arles puis déjà
prêts comme le quatre 5e commencé à
trouver ce diouf et j'en passe 12 total
fait que ce même pas encore en vie à
moitié puisque comment ça tu as trouvé
ça dur puis je savais toujours ce qui
s'en venait et si j'ai quand même un
mystère comme à chaque mort de deux
semaines barjac mort dit je sais
apprécier les maquettes et jeudis
vendredis samedis jours vont mettre les
jours jean marc filet fait que sais je
commençais à trouver c'est de plus en
plus durs puis ce qui est arrivé ce qui
a pris mon sixième traitement g20 de
cannes
et puis on voyait déjà que le cancer
était parti comme à 95%
c'est vraiment super nous verrons mais
j'étais juste le système traitement puis
à 6-6 au fait que le mont davantage
créer des partis à 95%
on va faire un coup à toulouse entre 1
13 ans elle finit mal au coeur ce nom
ont fait l'essai sont d'accord j'ai
cours d'une marché pourquoi laisser son
besoin de force puis effectuer c'est
quelque chose que j'ai beaucoup de
misère en fait à comprendre au début
pourquoi vraiment gens faciles ce puits
moi j'ai toujours été un peu quand même
pour implanter médicaments anti anti
virus
les vaccins puis dans le fond le thé
lipton il est utile de ne pas n'a plus
de plus la prendre sur 6 pour les
justement pour les maux de tête les mots
de banque puis j'en prenais vraiment le
strict minimum je voulais pas que mon
corps situation puis la chimiothérapie
c'est un peu se jeter comme je suis
vraiment besoin de fois les 6
le sis au team gt comment pendant ma
captivité
pilati la monnaie mais ce prix en
fonction à dix durant vingt quatre
parfums quatre métiers ici reste une
petite cellule car pas tout ton corps en
partie puis à 10 la deuxième fois que tu
fais là la chimiothérapie
ça marche c'est pas aussi efficace la
première fois tu fais qu'un discours ce
qu'on veut vraiment à faire plus que pas
assez pour vraiment que tu être sur le
tour des avoirs limite pour ça
commençait fait que rejeter cabba ok on
va continuer
mais si ça a été vraiment dur je me suis
rendu à la presse qu'au neuvième juste
et correct mais les 10 11 12 3 dernier
le g et j'avais moins de 1000
moi j'ai envie de tout arrêter j'étais
petite cabane sheremata mines préfecture
en plus se rentrer là dedans dans le
fond on est on est un petit peu un petit
peu méfiant par rapport à ces
traitements a loupé n'était pas 100%
convaincu ou non je t'ai pas méfiant par
rapport au traitement
afin de la chemise à motifs connaissez
un peu lâche mais dans l'ensemble je
savais qu est ce que ça allait faire au
cancer qu'est ce que ça faisait l'enfant
à ton cas puis non en fait c'est un
traitement qui est sceptique un cage du
ch compte les vaccins doute suis-je
points ce soir contre que guérir du
cancer tu réalises que la médecine
moderne la médecine c'est super bon ben
si je suis pour ça c'est vraiment juste
par rapport au dos c'était vraiment par
rapport au nombre de piles et en même
temps je suis allé faire quand j'ai fait
ma bio site et ils m'ont donné un pur
morphine avec jean king plus de dents
les mêmes peu pris une j'avais pas mal
mais je suis en fait je suis plus de
gens à prendre pilule à 20 d'abord avant
d'avoir septembre et j'aime mieux avoir
le saintongeais mais flémalle puis après
s'emparant d'une qui est des prix voire
avant là je vous rajoute pas que mon
corps s'habitue à ce succès plus mais
ton contre mnt à décembre 2018 dans le
fond quand il apprit pileux je m'attends
à tout dans la chronologie le savait pas
encore quel type de cancer s'était
finalement celle ci comment ça s'appelle
s'appelle lymphome de hodgkin une cuisse
et kate se sait quelque chose que
maintenant l'espérance de des rémissions
est quand même bonne chance
en fait si ces méthodes tu vas voir que
j'étais comme un peu chanceux dans ma
malchance quand on dit stacey c'était
comme dans un sens c'est une bonne
nouvelle - c'est la fin du parcours 10
km en 85% chances de réussir en vain
fait que pâques c'est sûr que ça a
boosté ma confiance aussi des batteries
pendant toute cette période là tu
touches pas un cheminot non en fait
mais ma dalton battant mais non moins
que je pourrais pas d'arrêter dans la
ville
à la moitié de mes traitements après
quatre cinquièmes geste dallas whistler
entre mes traitements fait que la faune
- comment ça se passait ce qui mettrait
bientôt deux semaines
la trois semaines je suis vraiment pas
bien deuxième semaine chez ben donc pour
trois traitements de suite
dandurand deuxième semaine j'ai toujours
à whistler quatre jours le temps puis
j'avais fait nos bords de l'agout
j'allais voir mes amis là bas puis je
ramenais pour une journée à damas puis
le feeling est quoi ce kit est ce que tu
étais complètement off de deux de tes
sensations que tu avais avant tout
accord devait être vraiment plus faible
extrêmement faible quand je faisais une
descente je faisais 10% les choses que
je faisais avant j'étais essoufflé au
bout depuis amman et je me rends hommage
tant que mon ami puis après comme 3,10
en tout cas on arrête on est petit ce
flux capable mais la raison que j'ai
fait sans fil
c'est parce que si ça fait dix ans que
je voyage puis le pense et moi j'allais
très tôt québec ce qui sauf sam à ce
petit jeu n'est pas habitué fait que le
pilote fétiche était vraiment routinier
ce que j'avais au québec le steak hommes
de deux semaines à maison empressé
hôpital ces maisons buteur maison plus
tard maison peut-être justement cette
année un peu avec le fait de comprendre
l'avion d'aller à lille allait prendre
la bonne heure dans les montagnes de
whistler
ça m'a fait du bien que c'était comme un
jeu [ __ ] et c'est comme mon vélo et de
l'hôpital puis le parachute et là-bas
pendant quatre jours je pensais même pas
l'hôpital
je n'ai qu'à me juger encore justement
le moment présent la boue puis
ça me faisait vraiment beaucoup de bien
parce que j'ai fait c'est pas ma pendant
trois 3 semaines de temps je faisais
trois fois dans un traitement puis bel
aperçu la scène house lost est finie
fait que parce que je reste à la maison
place puis dans ces moments là le webkit
fait état descente était saoul et des
stratégies ou est-ce que tout doute et
m'emmener quête allait revenir au niveau
qui était avant impôts du tout affaire
de l'été je savais que la chimiothérapie
salaire dit au pied puis un muscle en
fait c'est pas la chimio qui l'affectent
c'est juste parce que pendant trois mois
j'allais au jim prentice ont forcé pas
trop trottier parce que tout pour
l'énergie de faire sauter en bout de
ligne c'est j'ai fait 6 mois de
traitement
je me suis pas entraîné beaucoup je peux
faire beaucoup de sport non plus et
après on six mois mon cardio je n'avais
plus mes muscles pensy moite et à rien
faire c'est surtout partie multi axes et
je savais que ça être normal que
j'allais perdre tout ce qu'ils font puis
tout pendant toute cette période là dans
le fond tu t'es dit tant qu'à vivre une
expérience dans même où si bien faire un
documentaire puis à une caméra qui me
suit partout
jacques c était quoi la décision de
faire ce puits qu'est ce que ça change
et en processus maintenant
mais encore une fois que je me dis que
tu voyages post années j'avais toujours
rêvé de faire un film de snowboard le
phare des tricks puis le jeu pour faire
la compétition je reste à la maison que
bordeaux peut rien faire dit bonjour
faire un film
enfin pour un film de tricks mais au
beau chemin processus puis en fin de
compte avec ce puits mais la foi qui est
et rien là dedans c'est que documentaire
la fin du tout puis
mais cette étoffe quand même parce que
on voulait voir enfin un bon
documentaire le buste époque est confuse
interview puis surtout divo est sauvé
par le stylisme vraiment raconter
l'histoire avec les images elles-mêmes
qui pour faire s'il fallait confirmer
mon film est quasiment 5 jours/semaine 4
5 heures par jour fait qu'à chaque fois
il ya pas une fois que tu avais
l'hôpital sans caméra à ma femme pour
une fois je revenais chez nous les trois
quatre jours après 5 km en ma phase test
philippe aubert trouve une caméra de
toronto mike se faire chier le titre
était jamais raté parce que parce que tu
es je savais que le projet allait coup
en fait c'est sûr que mathis state of
lust st loup ramener la piété jeter
hashtag ma copine depuis toujours une
caméra dans ta face le puits
quand philippe robin et puis c'est le
fait que le bateau intimité et là je
fais que te montrer aussi dans des
moments aussi des flopées ou août et
attend plus justement faible de savoir
quand même villa aurait pas évident puis
en plus et bâti de base chez une
personne qui je garde souvent comme un
feeling en 12 mois puis je demander mon
chemin
kelley qui en font le directeur du
projet ces maladies ici il ya vraiment
fallu qu'il confirme pas mal plus pour
avoir ce moment là parce qu'ils te
rendent pas une personne qui s'ouvre
facilement des jeux le six de base mais
mais en bout de ligne j'ai vu en fait
les documentaires et les quelques
semaines on a fait un art of code ça
s'en vient bientôt
puis c'est bien ramassé quelque chose à
regarder sa part rappelle des moments
que j'ai récemment vu l'autre mais des
bons moments aussi
puis
mais on sait que moi je me mauger vous
allez feeling que je ressentais capable
de l'est puis le tu te fais après tout
traitement du retrait d'irak il le
cancer est partie complètement
qu'est ce qui se passe dans ta tête
qu'est ce qui se passe dans ton
d'anthony ou non quel mauvais temps là
donc ça a été confirmé que avec mon
dernier traitement je pensais comme le
12 juin
et puis ça a été confirmé arabi est cité
comme le 28 juin je savais que j'ai pu
cancer full web et et je savais déjà
qu'il aime à 95% après ce chimiste est
parti j'ai construit en investissant
dans ma tête j'étais comme je
m'attendais je m'attendais des gestes
que ce soit fini tes effet que ça l'est
encore une fois juste confirmé t je peux
sauter de joie demain parce que je le
savant dans moi je n'aurais pu puis mais
j'étais juste vraiment la saison j'étais
content des quand même d'en finir
je propose donc que j'ai commencé un
entraînement intense au bout d'eux parce
que j'avais deux mois pour pour me
rendre aux kings à north bay donc deux
mois pour tout retrouver cardio tout
retrouver le thymus que tu te retrouves
été tricks de snowboard eu 6 puis 8 670
qui est pas là en attendant le font
parce qu'il va bien pendant huit mois
petit j'ai pas envie de signer puis tous
les autres aillent de béton qui
continuent à donner meilleure donc mon
foot
en plus il faut que je redevienne bon
comme j'étais avant fois plus que j'en
apprends de plus pour revenir fait que
j'avais beaucoup des charges de travail
à faire je m'entraînais carrément ce
jour semaine comme comme un malade pour
petit système
c'était un défi que tire n'importe quel
athlète dirais c'est impossible tant
d'humour de retrouver une forme c
pis justement d'en avoir autant perdu
retrouvé une masse musculaire retrouver
tes réflexes en deux mois cc c'est du
jamais vu
j'étais tellement motivés puis en fait
c'est une des raisons pourquoi je
voulais comme arrêter la chimie ont
rendu que moi ou 9 9 dixièmes que
j'avais tellement hâte de recommencer à
m'entraîner que c'était comme une raison
pourquoi je commence à entraîner fils en
plus dans mon métier je t'aime à 2,3 ce
n'est plus le fait qu'ils entendent
moins rester calmes si je me sentais
vraiment comme un lion dans une cage à
massimo d'un tel homme venait d'ouvrir
la carte comme les doutes je peux dire
que j'ai couru entre la paroisse quand
on parle de visualisation j'imagine que
fait c'est toute cette période une
non-présence tous et qui parce que quand
tu fais là cheminots justement des
patates avariée
je pense à rien tu fis le juste mal le
peu d'énergie très peu d'énergie pour la
visualiser la visualisation a fait de
l'énergie pour rien faire du tout en
fait fait qu'il ya non j'ai pas envie tu
as des choses est ce que tu suivais la
saison que tu manques et moi j'ai gagné
toutes les compétitions de chênes verts
chim c'est sûr ça faisait très chaud
surtout thil ils ont commencé à changer
un peu les lakers pillowman y avait je
pense aux lionceaux puniet le corps est
vraiment beau ledger elle est vraiment
le fun que je caresse peux pas croire
que je manque si cette année
quand j'avais tellement envie d'arriver
slot pour les x games
après cette préparation express fille
est ce que est ce que tu arrives leur
pit est confiant que tu peux gagner le
truc où tu te dis je me retrouve un peu
dans l'opinion envers eux qu'est ce qui
arrive non j'étais confiant deux
semaines avant un mois puis enfin le bus
début c'était marrant luis games mais
c'était aussi bien c'était sur le
planning a fait dans ma tête
puis c'est en fait j'ai jamais fait de
combustion dans ma vie
saint georges même pas l'important c'est
rare que le timing l'important c'est de
participer
s'applique aux gagnants de ces gens ce
qu'ils gagnent les meilleurs le thé des
autres dans leur tête
l'important c'est de participer c'est
michael phelps ont bu c'était pas juste
de partir
non mais si on veut tout gagner c'est
séraphine même que dans mes débuts en
fait j'ai mis mes attentes étaient moins
un autre fait que sam et on choisit un
podium 3e le petit gros c'est cool mais
maintenant aujourd'hui j'arrive deuxième
puis sauvage que non content c'est sûr
mais pas comme un vertige comme j'aurais
mieux aimé sa première marche t way fait
que le feeling de gagner c'est vraiment
un feeling qui est incroyable aussi puis
s'est rendu mon standard c'est quand
c'est sur ce que je condamne et puis
fait le fait que le tarif ou x games se
fait par ron tulle end ont tué puis dans
ta tête tu gagnes et quand tu landes
je le savais que c'était un nouveau truc
était jamais fait non non c d ça faisait
comme un enjeu faisant compétition puis
en fait c'est ce qui ce qui était dû aux
x games et que ça me tombe juste la
finance habilité j'ai atterri métro au
saut puis il ya prenez juste et enfin
parler d'eux sur les trous avec ma
finale tout allait super bien et il
fallait un calife avant la qualif s'ils
prennent le meilleur sur dur puis mon
premier saut gelé j'ai tombé féclaz
merci je t'ai cabon prochain est aussi
sur des tombes c'est fini mais je pense
vous soit que je tombe puis c'est fini
puis je pouvais pas quoi vais-je avait
tellement de pression j'ai plus de
pression en qualif
donc c'est un moment avec beaucoup
beaucoup de pression que je content
d'avoir réussi à passer par dessus
puisque jean flare la pression j'ai
trimé sow puis écoutes dont je juge sa
bile mathis salles arrive des fois qu'
on est encore un jeune sport ça arrive
des fois son sport jugé
résistance possible ça m'est arrivé à
mettons à deux trois compétitions dans
ma carrière que je t'écris j'atterris
c'est ptet que je viens de gagner puis
boum ils ne font pas gagner les juges tu
arrives comme deuxième côté comme moi
c'est vraiment comme ce cadre sur cech
la compétition après tu es tu encore
qu'un tabarnak les juges m'ont volé ou a
totalement pillé
c'était arrivé ce de revoir après tout
faire messieurs de volley ça m'est
arrivé de 2,3 fois comme je dis est ce
qui m est ce que tout le monde autour de
toi les autres riders est ce que tout le
monde sans consensus généralisé des
faits de vol evènement bois puissants
comme je peux pas croire qu'ils ont fait
depuis le monde industrie réellement
puis puis même ça m'est arrivé une fois
que les juges n'avaient crise facebook
après pour me dire désolé on en a photo
qui n'ont pas le droit a rappelé ils ont
palois reprise vidéo
jacky des flops et mais ce n'est pas une
affaire de corruption c'est juste
compris mauvaise décision annoncée ce
que toi puis est arrivé mais métier ce
n'est pas juste à moi c'était un domaine
que je peux dire que j'ai déjà dans une
compétition qu'ils étaient davantage sa
deuxième médaille d'or puis c'était pas
mon cas mérite et il faut que ça se
balançant moring certains qui était le
but si ce souhait à coeur est là mais
metz et des affaires car et puis je peux
masseuse ça doit projeter dans mon sport
nous balancent des sports juger de sa
peut pas toujours être parfait savait
pas si le métis donc j'ai pris mon saut
puis comme dans ma tête je gagne c'est
sûr mais il restait encore d'enfant le
japonais yuki qui avait dit avait
atterri en fait le plus gros sous la
soirée c'est lui qui avait le plus haut
score puis il lui restait une descente à
faire il y avait atterri sur un autre
son deuxième nom c'est ce qui fait que
rien de juste atterri avec leur tout
dépend des taxis atterrissait sur son
deuxième saut un programme sur la
troisième descente puis qu'est-ce qu'il
faut que vous en disiez vous strict à 20
non non non en fait c'est une surprise
puis et puis je sais que yuki est très
bon il ya les très bons trucs ceci fait
qui a fait entre 10 et l'a fait je te
dis que je savais je dois rien déjà jeté
comme dans ma tête je n'aurais pas pu
mieux performer à compétition c'est dans
une très très bonne position puis en
fait la raison pourquoi je dis que je
savais que j'avais créé comme goris
parce que pendant qu'on fait les
pratiques on regarde les autres
on sait ce qu'ils vont faire et on sait
qu incarne la finale s'est jamais comme
une surprise
pour faire une fois pour cacher son nom
mais des fois ça arrive c'est quand même
assez rare
puis le jump en norvège c'était un job
qui était très très très avec un angle
comme je pense avec 52 degrés puis nommé
mandroso c'est comme 38 degrés s'est
instauré entre en piste est vraiment
comme pour la faire fuiter dans l'aréna
passé le premier saut à vie j'ai vu des
images de conscience jamais jamais
jamais vu sous mais parce que ça m'ait
jamais été à l'extérieur en haut de ce
temps soit rendant ce talent puis le
saut c'est comme dans un rêve mais c'est
la face et book sans arrêt ne le
souhaite être très limité très petit
puis c'était comme un nouveau saut
poutre montée c'était points sauf facile
donc j'avais vu les pratiques d or j'ai
vu les pratiques de yuki puis je savais
les succès les frères jeter clubs ont
les chances qui me sortent quelque chose
d'en face qui est pratiqué c'est comme
s'ils essayaient jose n'est pas pratiqué
les choses qui leur adressent du premier
coup sans l'avoir pratiqué sur ce sol où
et quand on fait un match et que d'après
moi je donne pas mal évidemment il y
aura pris son troisième sommet était
juste un point crucial m du régime est
ce que c'est la plus belle médaille d'or
que tu as eu celle qui a le plus de
valeur pour tous et maintenant où le kit
ressenti plus grand bonheur on gagne
c'est une bonne question c'est en fait
chaque médaille d'or comme son histoire
derrière c'est là ils sont quand même
parce qu ils y allaient être l'avocat
didier c'est ce qu'alain l'histoire est
très très spécial c'est ce qui est très
marquante mais c'est sûr que c'est la
seule méthode la méthode puis la
réaction de tout le monde qui était
l'hôte et autant des adversaires que le
public que les commentateurs que ton
équipe tu ce ça doit être ça change à
travers coûte 2
c'est de la france qu'il arrive ce que
tu me demandes si ces mamies dans ma
tête quand je repense à cette
compétition le je pense même pas la
médaille je t'aime mais c'est justement
parce que j'entends des images puis la
médaille je me repose sur podium je me
vois pas avec la médaille autour du cou
moi ce que je vois c'est vraiment le
grand et bel en crise ouais mais moi ce
que je vois dans ma tête c'est vraiment
le fait que je refais du snowboard de
code de compétition la première fois
quand comme dis-moi temps puis je vois
[ __ ] go que j'avais pas vu depuis des
mois puis j'aime et je me sens chanceux
l'éclat beau on s'est échangé des
sourires éclairaient tout le monde doit
y être une boîte c'est vraiment cool
puis
je me sentais comme juste bac 60 ans
inscrits puis juge a pris c'est vraiment
le moment présent à fond c'est ce que je
revois dans ma tête je repense à la
compétition il faut que je vois je vois
que j'ai comme le succès de mes deux
mois de travail puis comme je retournais
leur puis d'iphones puis mais je pense
même pas à la performance la beauce et
même pas ce que je vois ma tête c'est
épique par une tête sur les épaules
est-ce que c'est comme si comme la
première je vois que j'ai une
compétition qu'il voulait gagner puis
c'est quand même ce que je veux mais ça
prend faut que je fais une copie sont
passés comme peut-être peu juste ce qui
est important maintenant c'est comment
est important moins de vivre normalement
présentes avoir du fun pitbull ou citer
ceux de sam et on veut reprendre on agit
de dettes hangover pendant trois mois
l'été six mois voilà six mois à cinq ans
permettant qu'atteignent on veut le
lendemain d'après cyclisme allemand mais
ça mais ça fait 8 et le surlendemain des
pentes raides il restitue bien par être
mis aux voix
mais quand une expérience comme ce qui
est aussi longue aussi prolonger ce
feeling ne doit pas son arrêt c'est à
dire de dire astique t'es bien de
pouvoir faire ce que tu veux
le pouvoir par an fait gagner ta vie
avec ta passion de pouvoir voyager le
monde voir des amis farter proment que
ça reste c'est vrai que le plus gros des
coïts quelqu'un qui revient d'une
histoire comme nation aurait totalement
puis bien ce que je dis que maintenant
je suis je vraiment présent je pense pas
à ça à chaque jour sinon ça serait pas
cool un tir placé dé foot c'est sûr
pensé à tout ce monde à chaque fois que
j'y pense j'ai envie de vomir
alors ça me donne des faux mais j'ai
quand même des associations avec mon
cerveau que ça s'est fait durant le
processus puisse en fait c'est quelque
chose qui je trouve est vraiment will
parce que moi dans ma tête c'est comme
les assiettes les associations que ça
vous pourrez voir dans ma tête je
croyais à pois ce pilot j'en ai vécu
moi-même jamais ouverte à mon esprit par
rapport à sur chaque fois jean vente
dans l'hôpital
je vous me 7,8 dont la santé l'hôpital
chaque fois qu'ils me faisaient porter
un masque bleu pendant comme le
traitement
j'aimerais vous remet quand il
désinfecte la peau avant de mettre les
gants ça sent l'alcool à rivaux mais
peut-on vraiment eu très peu mettre un
masque désinfecter les mains des propos
de masquer le fait que je me suis acheté
un masque en tissu mais si tu mets un
masque bleu en face ça se peut bien que
j'ai envie de vomir mettons souvent à
l'hôpital pour une raison ça vaut se
lever le camp non mais j'ai tenu à la
semaine passée pour faire en fait une
irm de marché de cet hiver jeune équipe
voici sept étaient amis auraient
justement ce qui est dit que juriste
puis puis encore se rendre à l'hôpital
puis la senteur ggc encore séoul
j'ai apprécié en fait j'ai mal au ventre
ces programmes c'est fou ça qui est mon
cerveau il ya quand même fait des
associations par rapport à ce puits puis
c'est encore aujourd'hui
pis même qui en mettant mois avant celle
d'un gros fan des cafés lattés et
j'adorerais ce qui j'en ai un but et
jean bizet comme à tous les jours
justement durant ma chimio aussi puis
amman et j'ai frappé un mur puis
maintenant aujourd'hui on me sert un
l'at-il puis je me suis engagé je vais
avoir envie de vomir encore une fois
c'est débile puis jetée match pareil ce
qui tue qui nous écoutent qui vont
peut-être un jour faire de la
chimiothérapie
évitez de consommer n'importe quoi que
vous aimez présentement pauvre et c'est
exactement ce qui est en fait j'étais
chanceux de pouvoir comme partager mon
expérience justement qui ont un grand
public parce qu'il ya beaucoup de monde
qui avaient soit par cet art cancer ou
qui étaient en train de faire quand ça
présentement
j'étais là chemin thérapie puis il
m'écrivait puis justement me disais que
marc est de manger petit duc et aime
parce qu'ils l'aiment rompu après année
pour des buses à coucher qui parle
métier puis en vraiment
c'est fou comment le cerveau fait des
associations par rapport à la
chimiothérapie
c'est système en quelque chose qui est
paul von affaire que c'était à chaque
fois que le nouvel hôpital
comme je vous dirais que je m'interdis
d'infection encore aujourd'hui quand je
pense à ces moments le ca me lève un peu
le coeur un peu donc ccc rock et j'y
pense mais c'est vraiment comme je mon
mode de vie est comme change et puis
c'est en fait ce que je peux dire
aujourd'hui c'est ça la connaît mais ce
qui m'est arrivé n'a pas cessé en fait
j'ai la chair échoué comme ce qu'ils
puissent d'un lip town est normal ou
deux fois sur jaffrès encore ce soir
c'est apporter comme en progression
c'est fou comment ça ça m'a changé pour
le mieux que je me contente c'est vrai
la drôle à dire mais non mais c'est ici
c'est vraiment la personne qu il est
plus heureux encore puis c'est pas peu
dire non à quelqu'un qui est un
snowboarder professionnel c'est dix fois
plus heureux que quelqu'un qui vit son
rêve
non mais j'ai j'apprécie vraiment le
moment
vraiment beaucoup plus pied c'est le fun
c'est vraiment mal fans même si son
drake s'est inspiré inspira vraiment
commonweath conduit qu'est-ce qu'on fait
ou est ce qu'on tchèque tes affaires
pour le monde qui écoute le kick
découvre qu'il connaissait déjà
ben c'est vraiment c'est ce sur les
réseaux sociaux s'aggravent facebook
sinon c'est vraiment la plus grande des
pistes de de diffusion éventuelle
c'est en fait on est encore en train de
regarder ça va être diffusé ou donc ce
n'est pas encore défini
est ce qu'ils t'ont suivi jusqu'à oslo
c'est une nation documentaire c'est
selon les goûts tiens tu peux pas le
prendre et plus je m'étends rapidement
toit après oslo il s'est passé quoi le
jeu cette saison là il va être terminé
le calme étant la saison 2010 9 je me
sentais plus rien en faire une autre
saison finisse toujours au mois d'avril
à la presse que le début de la saison on
rejoue puis mettez une compétence dans
les textes toujours comme ça avec un
autre trois mois sans compétition mais
en fait ce qui est ce qui était bizarre
puisque j'ai compris en fait pourquoi sa
défaite soit après c'est que je suis
revenu de selous et je me sentais super
bien énergique cardio est revenue
limites sont revenus mon énergie est
elle aussi
puis le genre de la maison puis tout
d'un coup plus d'énergie le moins qui
dort des 13 14 heures par jour pendant
trois semaines atteint je fais le pas du
tout pas du tout j'ai pu nergie la
fatigue accumulée de tractage
d'énergie pour faire des prises de sang
en tchèque sur tout est beau c'est
pourtant avec un frappeur puis
finalement j'ai parlé de mon psychologue
sportif qui est ici on a compris par la
suite que je me suis je me suis battue
du mois de janvier jusqu'au mois de juin
pour combattre le cancer
si c'est pas juste de flémalle pour me
raconter ton qu il se bat pendant tout
ce temps le ccdh renner ça draine
beaucoup d'énergie après ceux de 2001
jusqu'à ou nintendo les secouristes gros
horloge pas j'ai jamais dit vacances le
8 mois de test et comme c'était fou le
mode à chaque jour du fait qu'il soit le
seul mois de septembre j'ai craché
complètement j'ai dormi je dormais pas
de cet homme car il a tout ça comment en
ce moment aujourd'hui après la coved
après tout près et encore lol mais on
est sympa ça va bien puis bah c'est sûr
que là comme au début de l'hiver
j'avais peur comme pony les cours à
chantenay compétition fait voyager le
monde et les eaux vertes des jet lag un
peu c'était ma première saison après
avoir battu de cancer je savais pas
comment mon corps allait réagir se peut
pas mon énergie
metronomy on a mis en place justement
des façons de com et d'autres tentent
plus de plus de temps de repos puis
finalement j'ai pas s'attendre saison
puis je consommais encore aujourd'hui le
chi parce que j'ai toujours dit les gens
la personne football les jo puis mais
maintenant que - j'ai commencé à faire
un peu de yoga non bâti jaffe une fois
deux semaines mais un peu de lui même à
chaque fois j'en fais parfois grosse ça
fait du bien fait comme intégrer un
programme on aura plus de temps libre
billy fait la queue vite zappé côté
vraiment la saison flamand en fait moi
j'ai été très chanceux parce que
j'imagine en compétition qui était l'ex
games contre x en norvège
c'était le 6 ou le 7 mars et puis le ch
est revenu à la maison comme les
le nez ça je faisais mes interviews
rappelons qu'un je dis je des interviews
un jeu il dit puis je sais ce que vous
allez voir à grinder qui jeudi soir puis
les lions annoncé lundi tout quand
céline les écoles ferment puis le 6
places et pis mais moi c'était planifié
que tu m as dedans à compétir l'année
des jeux à bon fait ma saison était
finie
certains qui étaient comme j'étais dans
tout ça on a toujours un autre côté de
nos boisés de faire des films qui m'ont
d'avril jeu left banke construit tout le
mois filmer ce qui n'est pas arrivé
malheureusement mais mais moi je suis
une personne que chaque situation qui
arrive j'essaie toujours de voir sur un
côté positif de comme tout est une façon
que ce soit le fossé s'est ces places
qui arrivent mais comme vous trouver une
façon qui de joe hill à la victime d'une
grosse max prenons un mois et demi of
j'ai pas fait ça pendant dix ans en
avril jusqu'à mi mai j'ai pris ce off
j'ai vu personne chez nous dans le bois
chaves mon terrain pour lui pis ça fait
du bien
au moins cela suffit la presse à partir
de mi mai ou le jir commencé à
m'entraîner un peu tranquillement chez
moi puis à bouger un peu plus pu
repartir la machine plus des prisons ne
reste au wac aux propriétaires
commencent à peu la brasserie moderne
numéro 7 c à saint jean puis c'est à
foncer japonais et portugais merci
beaucoup mais resta plaisait tellement
inspirant ton parcours dans l'histoire
en même temps passions surtout je pense
seul soja retire le plus son duel mais
un adversaire semaine